meu nome
olha este nao so sírio
nascido em damasco capital da síria e os
de engenharia na universidade de damasco
hoje sou filiado no brasil com minha
família em língua maior hobby oab um
bocado diferente do português à x da
guerra
assim era bonita e tranquila barata e
fácil de se viver
abobo sal era da 23 milhões de pessoas
eu tenho a minha família amigos e
conhecia desde criança precisa hoje de
roupa um instrutor e de engenharia
dois apartamentos e um carro em damasco
eu gostava de viajar é adorava conhecer
um mundo
fui para países como estados unidos
espanha e frança
até que um dia começou a guerra o
conflito começou em 15 de março de 2001
em 2011 será de bois chico a todas as
outras cidades do país
minha cidade damasco era e mais segura
da síria tinha entre 21 e 25 de bomba
por dia de boi de cinco anos de guerra
o meu país está destruído
eu acho que conheço foram obrigadas a
carregar o cadáver de seus filhos
encontraram suas esposas seria feridas e
morte da mochilla dadas por uma bomba
familiares só miró e não votaram nem os
últimos anos da síria fora muito difícil
e não sabia se a voltar pra casa quando
saía para trabalhar seria ver a minha
família de novo uno hoje milhão disse
rassi bedran perderam tudo estão mortos
o seu filho já outros países
eu e minha família estávamos muito
triste quando tivemos que deixar a síria
pois nossos bari x em nossa vida ficaram
para trás
eu ainda não sei se vou conseguir voltar
a um mundial me o país nem o pai e meu
irmão ainda morar melhor e não sei se
vou ver eles novamente eo teve apenas
uma semana para deixar pra trás
quarenta anos da minha vida e começar de
novo no brasil e não conhecia nada sobre
o brasil só tinha escutado falar um
bocado sobre o rio de janeiro salvá-lo
amazonas e futebol
eu cheguei no brasil em dezembro 2013
com minha esposa e dois filhos
ôrí alto
com 11 anos era muito homem uma pessoa
da mesquita recebeu no aeroporto ele num
regime dou na sua casa boa três meses e
fiz muitas coisas bar anos sem nos
conhecer cadastrou mim os filhos na
escola
o google books para mim para vender
roupa na feirinha da madrugada
ml o gol um apartamento porque e não
tinha documentos
na semana que eu cheguei aqui já
começará a participar das aulas de
português de uma ong de boi de cinco
meses e eu consegui homem grego na minha
área como engenheiro em uma empresa mas
logo foi demitido por causa de falta de
projetos
eu comecei a procurar outras opções
eu tinha certeza e sinopense consegui
esse trabalho como engenheiro e é achar
outra forma de recomeçar a vida no país
já tinha feito abate mais difícil fugir
da guerra homem dia eo fez uma festa
para comemorar o aniversário dos meus
filhos e todos falharam muito bem da
comida que minhas boas efes e um
entender que tinha uma oportunidade não
conhecia o dono do sítio da comida nas
sabia que tinha ombro do típico da síria
que os brasileiros brasileiros iam
gostar
foi aí que começamos nosso negócio
a ge de começar a vender para todo toda
a cidade e decide decidir fazer alguns
desses tomar amigos eles me falavam
quais serão os pratos mais saboroso e
qual era e melhor for a forma de
apresentar minha comida
depois de algumas semanas eu já estava
pronto para começar a vender aquele
antes de verdade
hoje em dia eu faço com mídia entregou
na cidade
recebemos encomendas até boas op
comecei também a dar aulas de culinária
síria eo ensinou a fazer robôs falhar
feio eu café da manhã
silio também me sinto me de nove eventos
duro durante o mês do ramadã preparava a
comida na mesquita do bari 400 pessoas
por dia
mas pessoas me conheceram foi chamado
para entrevistas em revistas e programas
de tv
minha página do facebook começou a
receber cada vez mais encomendas
agora precisava de uma loja maior para
poder atender a todos os clientes
precisava também me mudar para um bairro
mais perto dos clientes porque perdia
muito tempo fazendo as entregas para
isso precisava de mais dinheiro em tal
eu vejo uma campanha para arrecadar
dinheiro em site de arrecadação o
positiva
o certo e consegui 72 mil reais ao por
aí com uma jornalista me perguntou como
eu ia abrir um negócio maior agora se a
economia do brasil estava ruim
eu mandei penapolense ao brasil a x e
não sabia ser que o nome era melhorar
antes ou não a primeira vez
a única coisa que eu sabia e que esta
era a minha chance
eu tinha é aproveitar o momento para
abrir um negócio no brasil
eu vi que eu recomendo o seguinte sal
três coisas 1 trabalhar muito e dormir
boku brasil é um país com muitas
oportunidades nas você precisa ficar de
olho o tempo todo bar a aproveitar as 27
adaptar à demanda dos clientes falhar
com os clientes o tempo todo aqui tenho
vários tipos de clientes em damasco
esse som um cultura uma cultura todas as
mesmas gostamos das mesmas coisas
em são paulo tem muitas torturas por
causa das imigrações o interessante é
que você pode identificar isso o bairro
no braço e vender comida slb kanji na
barraca que conseguiu em pinheiros e
vendeu comida com outro sabor
em dois fiascos um e joão
por ter alguns clientes brasileiros
gostar disso três saber como lidar com a
burocracia brasileira do exame o que eu
queria abrir um restaurante em são paulo
mas me explicaram que ia levar seis
meses para conseguir os documentos
quintal e decidir abrir ou melhor já de
comida síria e mais fácil
nós estamos felizes no brasil
agradecemos o recebi sal do povo
brasileiro
hoje eu me sinto parte do povo até tenho
uma filha brasileirinha assar ó
de novo nem se ele está aqui no teatro
com minha esposa e meus outros deus que
dois filhos
vocês abriram as botas quando o mundo
estava fechado bar anos talvez eu vou te
a síria há algum dia nas agora estou
focado no brasil era eu recomeçar minha
vida nesse país
mesmo caso mesmo com as dificuldades que
temos board finanças da cultura e
religião com a maioria das pessoas e um
caminho difícil mas eu sei que tenho
sorte de estar aqui na source e muitos
outros irmãos não têm de verão eu ver eu
vejo meus filhos indo para estourar esse
que não corre perigo no brasil
não vivo mais o medo da guerra
meu sonho a partir de agora ai de mim os
filhos e sem os filhos
o santos ser juntos em base você na
maliki